- Always been people have been taught
that they must work hard.
Nobody told them they must work joyfully.
Most human beings have
crippled themselves.
Simply because of fear of suffering.
What will happen to me?
Is always the question.
Every idea, every thought, every emotion
every value that you have
is picked up from somewhere
and it rules you from within.
- He's a man whose passion spills
into everything he encounters.
He infects his zest for life
into all those who seek to
live their life to the fullest.
He's the author of Inner
Engineering: A Yogis Guide to Joy
which is a New York
Times best selling book.
He is Sadhguru and here is my take
on his top ten rules
for success, volume two.
And as always guys, as
you're watching the videos
if you hear something that
really resonates with you
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
Also, as you are writing something down
it's much more likely to
stick in your head too.
Enjoy.
(upbeat inspiring music)
- You can live life with ease.
Not with struggle.
One thing is, when we say work
it's many young people, wonderful people
who are getting recognized for whatever
wonderful things they have done.
Leaving them apart but
generally work means
always been people have been taught
that they must work hard.
Nobody told them they must work joyfully.
Nobody told them that work should be
an expression of their joy or their life.
They have to work hard.
You work hard, life will be tedious.
How else will it be?
You will do something hard
only because you don't know how to do it.
If you know how to do it,
you will do it with ease.
So without learning how to do
something if you try to do it
without investing enough
time and perception
if life is all expression
than life becomes a big struggle.
Not a single day passes for me.
- [Woman] Right.
- Without witnessing tears
of joy and love around me.
Every day.
Somebody will be shedding
tears of love and joy.
I don't think there's a better way to live
in this world.
(laughs)
And all of us should strive
to create our own circles
of joyfulness and pleasantness around us.
Because if you're not
joyful by your own nature
if you're always going around
with the fear of suffering
as long as fear of suffering
is there within you
you will never walk your
life with full stride.
It will always be half a step.
Most human beings have crippled themselves
simply because of fear of suffering.
What will happen to me?
Is always the question.
Whatever happens, this is how I will be.
If this assurance comes to you
only now you will want to
scale the peaks of life
and see what about it.
If it happens, makes no difference to you.
If it doesn't happen,
makes no difference to you.
That's when you would like to
really explore every dimension of life.
So first and foremost thing is this
that your way of being is not determined
by what's around you.
If you bring this one aspect to you
there is no fear of suffering.
Once there is no fear of suffering
you will traverse the breadth
and length of this life.
Without hesitation.
When the result of the event
has no impact on you.
Both ways you're blissed out.
You're a success.
When the fruit of the action
does not determine how you are
it's just that you do things
because of the exuberance of what you do
then you are a success.
The result may depend
on variety of things.
Results are not always yours.
For any result to happen
whether it's in a game
or in life situations
there are various factors involved
not all of it is in our control.
But what is in our control
is either we did our best
or we did not do our best.
That's in our control.
As long as we're doing that
and whatever the result may be
if you're still blissed out
that means you are a success
because life cannot defeat you anymore.
Being playful
always has been understood
as irresponsibility.
Yes?
Do you know, right from your childhood
and probably to your children.
They're just playful.
You think it's irresponsible.
The most responsible way to live
is that you're playful with life.
It's absolutely irresponsible
to carry a long face and
walk around on this planet.
Yes or no?
Isn't it absolutely irresponsible
to walk around with misery?
Yes.
That's the most irresponsible
thing you can do.
So being playful is not irresponsibility
being playful is being very responsible
and responsive to life.
Only when you are
playful, you can do that.
When you are serious, the
world doesn't exist for you.
You and your nonsense.
Yes.
When you are silly it's just
about you and your nonsense.
The world and other life
does not exist for you.
Only when you are playful.
You can pay attention to everything.
You can truly respond to
everything in the world
only if you're playful
otherwise you cannot.
Just a burden, enough it will kill you.
- How to conquer fear on the body
on the way to success.
That is all.
- Okay, fear about whether I
would be successful or not?
Where does that fear come in?
Your individual fear about
will I be successful or not?
Is that what you are talking?
I think that's exactly what I
have been telling you till now
don't even think of success.
Just enhance your capabilities.
Strive to enhance who you are.
And what you can do you
will never do, resent it.
Right now, you have an idea of success
but you don't have the
competence for that.
You want to go somewhere
but you don't have the legs to get there.
Now naturally there will be fear.
Naturally there will be all kinds
of unnecessary struggles and emotions.
Accept that at this stage in your life
if you just focus on seeing how to enhance
this human being to the
highest possible level
that you can
success will be a downhill
run not an uphill task.
So if you are going downhill
there is no fear isn't it?
Because whether I can get there or not
whether I can get there or not
you are working towards
somebody elses idea of success.
You are working towards
That is not success.
Your successes, you as a human being
you found your full potential.
This is your success.
And that's all you can do.
Whether you stand on your head
or you stand on your feet.
The best that you can do.
If this human being finds
his fullest potential
that's all you can do.
No matter what you do
you cannot do more isn't it?
Certain circumstances
sometimes will loft us up.
Certain circumstances sometimes may not.
But in the given circumstance
if you have blossomed
to your fullest level
you will do well isn't it?
Don't think of success
and be fearful about it.
Just see how to make this one
more and more capable.
If the competence and capability is there
success will come as we deserve it.
All of human experiences
generate from within.
Is that so?
All human experiences
generated from within.
So at any time, if you
feel happy or unhappy
miserable, joyful, excited
in a state of agony.
It doesn't matter what happens.
What is your experience?
Pleasantness or unpleasantness?
Just to know that it's
happening from within.
And it can only happen from within.
You can either take external stimuli
or you can create your own stimuli
but essentially it happens from within.
This one thing if it is not grasped
when you feel miserable,
if you think it's this one
you're gone.
You're just, the keyboard is here
but you're punching the wall.
It's not going to work.
This one basic fundamental thing
is something that almost
90% of the humanity
is always doing it wrong.
Whenever they feel miserable
they think it must be this one or that one
or that one or that one.
No.
All human experiences
generate from within.
If something is feeling unpleasant
first thing is to look at this.
What am I doing wrong with this?
Am I eating wrong, am I sleeping wrong
am I sitting wrong, am I breathing wrong
is my heart beating wrong?
Something.
My chemistry is wrong.
Something is wrong with
this, not with that.
So the moment you think
by kicking the wall
you can fix this one
then you made a fundamental mistake.
The harder you try, the
further away from it you go.
The first thing is to bring balance.
Once there is balance,
then you can build a tower
on top of this.
If there is no balance
whatever you build will
only lead to more trouble.
The more basic you are, the better it is.
So this is what a whole
lot of humanity is seeking
somehow to remain basic
because if you build
something, it feels terrible
then there is no fundamental balance.
Anything standing up without
balance is a big problem.
It is somebodys idea
of what is success isn't it?
Don't become a slave to somebodys idea.
At least have your own idea.
You have no idea of your own
don't deceive yourself.
Every idea, every thought, every emotion
every value that you have
is picked up from somewhere
and it rules you from within.
It rules you from within.
Your religion, your society, your culture
has trained you to
believe that this is it.
So the first and foremost success is
that you are not a slave to anybodys idea.
This is success.
If you come to the idea
of mortality once in a way
it will make you depressed.
It will make you fearful.
If you live with it every moment
it will make you absolutely
exuberant and alive
because it is just this one thing.
That this is not forever.
This is just for a brief period of time.
And the more joyful you
are, briefer it becomes.
If you're ecstatic, it
will just vanish in no time
(laughs)
Yes?
So if you want to stretch it
you need to make yourself truly miserable.
(audience laughs)
Otherwise, it will be
just gone in no time.
If you come to terms with this
if you live this way
that every moment you
appreciate one thing.
And only one thing
because the most important
thing in your life
is you're alive right now, to be alive.
Fully alive, 100% alive
is the most important thing
because only if something is 100% alive
can you make it in something beautiful.
A human being does not become who he is
because of his desire.
He becomes who he is
because of his competence.
So by enhancing your competence
you're just enhancing your desire
which will be just as horrible
burden to carry all the time.
You just focus on enhancing
the competence of who this is
rather than enhancing your desire
that I'm going to become a world champion.
Everybody wants to become one
they're not going to become one isn't it?
Everybody wants to be successful
they will not be a success
unless you do the right things.
Success will not happen to you.
Can I tell you a joke?
(audience laughs)
45 minutes, you've got to be serious.
- A joke now?
- We can?
- Okay.
Tell me the joke.
Okay let me ask you this question.
- Well let me tell you a joke.
(audience laughs)
- Even better.
- On a certain day, a man
fell into a septic tank.
Right up to here in filth.
He desperately tried to
come out, he could not.
Then he started screaming, "Fire, fire!"
Neighbors heard this,
called the fire brigade.
Firemen came rushing.
They looked all over the place, no fire.
Then they found this man.
They pulled him out and they asked
"Why were you screaming fire?
"Where is the fire?"
The man retorted, "If I said
shit, shit, would you come?"
(laughing)
You got to do the right things
otherwise right things
will not happen to you.
Just because you have a big desire
you're not going to get there.
You have to do the right things.
Rarely is situations in your life
either you can use it
to make yourself stronger and better
or you can sit and cry.
This is the choice you have.
Everything, it doesn't matter what happens
the most horrific event
happened in your life
that also can be used for your growth
and your well being.
If only, if you have clearly seen
the small events of your life.
When I say small events,
I mean your business
your marriage, your children,
all those big things.
(audience laughs)
All these things are just a stepping stone
so the fear of failure.
Failure is bad enough.
Fear is adding spice to it isn't it?
(laughs)
Success happens to you
not because you desire it
because you earn it.
Everybody desires it.
It comes only if you're capable of it.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
We're continuing in this series
of the volume two episode
so I'd love to know what you guys think
and if there's anybody
you want to nominate
for volume two, let me know.
I'm also really curious to figure out
what did you learn from Sadhguru today
that had the biggest
impact on you and why?
What message did you take
that you're going to immediately apply
somehow to your life or to your business.
Leave it down in the comments below
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I want to give a quick
shout-out to Rhonda Young.
Rhonda, thank you so much for your support
in buying my book Your One Word.
I really, really, really,
really appreciate it.
(upbeat music)
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- Winning an election.
(audience laughs)
- [Man] If you want to win an election
that's how luck is also incurred.
(laughs)
- Pray to God.
Luck, effort.
Maybe all of them?
But in what proportion?
So when you say faith
obviously it's something
that you cannot do
anything about.
When you say luck, again
obviously it's something
that you cannot do anything about.
When you say God, again it's something
So the only thing in your hands is effort.
So put 100% into your effort
what happens, happens isn't it?
(applause)
But don't leave proportions of your energy
and your capability to luck, God, faith
all those things.
That's not your business
if there is such a thing
it will act.
Your business is only effort isn't it?
Just do that.
Effort has to be incisive in a sense.
It should be focused, calibrated.
Simply if you make effort
it's foolish effort isn't it?
Just labor is not going
to get you somewhere.
The right kind of action, the right timing
right place, all this
is important isn't it?
So for all these things to happen
you need perception and intelligence.
So that's all you must do in your life.
Constantly looking for ways
to enhance your perception
and your intelligence.
The rest will anyway happen.
This is one thing that
unfortunately humanity is not doing.
They're trying to become
capable of something.
Do not try to become capable of something.
Just enhance your
perception and intelligence.
Whatever comes your way.
Right now, let us say it's like this
you know, this is happening
in the world all the time.
Everybody wants to become a doctor.
Not now, if 25 years it was so.
If you wanted to study,
first thing is medicine.
If you don't get a seat, what's next?
Engineering.
Don't get a seat, what?
Next thing, next thing, like this.
So let's say you became a doctor
and let us say
everybody came to a yoga program
and they stopped going to a doctor
at least your visits to the
doctor has come down isn't it?
Has it?
Has it come down or not?
For sure, it's come down.
So business will go down.
It will no more be a good
profession to go into
because very few doctors
are becoming doctors
because they want to become doctors.
Others are becoming doctors because
they think it's lucrative.
Isn't it?
Isn't it so?
Most people are becoming doctors because
they think somebodys sickness
is a lucrative business.
It's very, I don't want to
go into all the aspects.
It's quite disturbing for me.
(laughs)
There are few doctors who
really want to be that.
They want to understand the human system
and they want to serve in that direction.
That's great.
Suppose everybody became healthy.
You don't want that isn't it?
You don't want that.
So do not try to put up a recipe
for your success.
Success is only when you
are able to use yourself
to your full potential.
It doesn't matter whether
you become a doctor
or a politician
or a yogi, or what the hell you become.
It's not the thing.
Success means you are living your life
to your full potential.
That's what success means.
If that has to happen
you need perception and
an active intelligence.
How do I grow my intelligence?
Don't worry about that.
Right now, the important thing
is to enhance your perception.
If you're able to see
life just the way it is
you have the necessary
intelligence to conduct it well.
If you're not able to
see life the way it is
your intelligence will work against you.
Most intelligent people on this planet
are generally the most
miserable people on the planet.
This is simple because
they have an active intelligence
but no perception of life.
So, one thing.
One most important thing
that people have not worked at
is to enhance their perception.
They're trying to broaden their mind.
That's not the point.
That will only make you
socially successful.
Not truly successful.
If you want to be truly successful
you must be able to see everything
just the way it is.
Without distortions.
If you can see everything
just the way it is
life becomes a play.
You can play joyfully
you can play it well for sure.
If you can play it well
people will say you're successful.
You should never think,
"I want to be successful."
Don't ever think, "I
want to be successful."
Just see how to make this being
into your full fledged being.
People will say one day,
"Oh he's successful.
"He's a great success."
You should not be aspiring for success
it's a miserable way
to structure your life.
You will simply cause pain
and suffering to yourself
and suffering to everybody
because your idea of success is sitting
on top of somebodys head isn't it?
Yes or no?
Your idea of successes right now
everybody should be below you
you must be at the top.
This is your idea of success.
This is not success, this is sickness.
So do not ever think of success.
Just see how to make this
into your full fledged being.
This is will find expression.
If it finds good expression
people around you will say
"Oh he is a great success."
That's fine.
People should recognize your success.
You should not be thinking
how to be successful.
Very wrong way to approach life.